la Vallée des Rois nécropole des
dignitaires et des pharaons et parmi eux
le plus grand que l'Égypte est jamais
connue tout en Camon le pharaon au
masque d'or
il y a 100 ans la première marche menant
à son tombeau a été découverte par
l'archéologue oward Carter financé par
l'égyptologue et philanthrope l'ordre
carnarvone
après des années de fouilles et des
tonnes de gravats déplacés un des rois
les plus mystérieux le 11e pharaon de la
18e dynastie livrait enfin une partie de
ses secrets il est évident que avec ses
5000 tous ces quelques 5300 objets qui
ont pris presque une dizaine d'années à
recenser c'était le plus gros trésor
funéraire qu'on a qu'on ai mis au jour
de ton histoire pharaonique donc c'est
de l'ordre de l'argent de libaine de
l'ivoire des objets des meubles un
trésor inestimable un arrêt sur image de
la vie quotidienne des Égyptiens du
Nouvel Empire vous savez tous ces
colliers de fleurs qu'on voit
représenter sur les fresques bien là le
corps de Toutankhamon en est orné on a
ces bouquets de fleurs donc pour
l'histoire de la botanie par exemple ça
a été une excellente avancée on a de
l'alimentation donc par exemple
également savoir comment les anciens
Égyptiens se nourrissaient
une véritable tout en Mania sans part de
la planète le jeune pharaon et le fils
de la reine Néfertiti à la beauté
légendaire et du roi Akhenaton qui avait
réformé le culte en Égypte on l'appelle
le roi enfant donc en effet il est il a
été porté donc sur le trône à l'âge de 9
ans on suppose vers l'âge de 9 ans et
donc selon les analyses de sa momie il
serait décédé autour de l'âge de 19 ans
mort jeune sans descendance ce sera son
grand-père qui lui succédera un siècle
après ses découvertes majeures le trésor
du tombeau de Toutankhamon continue de
révéler ses secrets mais saviez-vous que
ce trésor n'est pas le sien en grande
majorité et qu'à l'origine il
appartenait à une femme donc ça a été
prouvé on a les noms de cette femme qui
a été donc elle s'appelait néfert
néféron cette reine Pharaon qui a été
effacée de l'histoire entre la légende
de ce roi important de l'Egypte
pharaonique et les mystères qui
l'entourent la croyance populaire s'est
vite emparée de Toutankhamon donnant
même naissance au mythe de la
malédiction de la momie ici Yasmine
Khayat Radio-Canada Montréal